un cine cobra 1050 por boleto y 5 por
bolsa de palomitas tú nunca compra de
las palomitas porque te parece que son
muy caras el precio total de lo que
pagas es proporcional al número de
boletos que compras bueno esto está
interesante porque nos dan el precio de
la bolsa de palomitas pero también nos
dicen que nunca compramos las palomitas
de hecho no sé por qué no dicen el
precio de las palomitas quizá quieran
confundirnos así que el precio total de
lo que pagas es proporcional al número
de boletos que compras pues solo vamos a
comprar boletos no vamos a comprar
palomitas así que si vamos a pagar 1050
por cada boleto por lo que debería ser
proporcional y para verlo un poco más
claro vamos a dibujar una tabla aquí el
número de boletos
y aquí el precio
es el precio total suponiendo que nunca
se compran palomitas si yo compro un
boleto el precio será de 1050
si compro dos boletos el precio será dos
veces 10 50 o 21 si compro 3 boletos
será tres veces 10 50 que serán 31 50
así que la razón o la proporción entre
el precio y el número de boletos
siempre será 1050
1050 dividido entre 121 dividido entre
230 y 150 dividido entre 3
siempre será 1050
y esto es porque si lo ponemos de otro
modo el precio es igual a 1050
multiplicado por el número de boletos
número de boletos
así que obviamente hay una relación de
proporción